[Musique]
le président Trump se remet du
coronavirus
et l'Amérique aussi ensemble, nous avons
relevé le défi de
protéger nos personnes âgées en leur procurant des
médicaments vitaux en un temps record,
sans épargner aucune dépense, le président Trump s'est
attaqué de front au virus en
tant que dirigeants si je peux '  Je n'imagine pas que
quelqu'un puisse
faire plus
[Musique]
Je suis connecté par téléphone tout au long de la
journée et jusque tard dans la nuit quand je dis nuit
je parle
12 1 2 le matin je ne suis pas le
seul il y a tout un groupe de  nous
qui faisons ça donc je ne peux pas imaginer
qu'en
aucune circonstance que
quelqu'un puisse
faire plus de
contexte existe
[Rires]
est [
Musique]
Rires]
euh [
Musique]
étrangère [
euh
[Rires]
étrangère
[  Musique]
euh
étrangère
[Musique]
est
étrangère à
toi